va bien évidemment parler avec vous du
pass vaccinale puisque ça y est le
parlement a donc définitivement adopté
ce texte on va d'abord en parler avec
vous alex est d'abord en quoi va donc
consister se passe vaccinale maintenant
que le texte définitivement voté et bien
oriane cela signifie que bientôt il
faudra avoir un schéma vaccinal complet
pour pouvoir entrer dans certains
établissements recevant du public comme
les bars les restaurants les cinémas les
musées les salles de sport ce serait
également de demander pour les
transports inter régionaux et puis les
gérants de ces établissements pourront
vérifier l'identité des clients qui
présentent leurs passes vaccinale
impasse vaccinale qui ne s'appliquera
qu'aux plus de 16 ans pour les 12 15 ans
ce sera toujours le passé ni terre alors
qu'en se passe vaccinale va-t-il entrer
en vigueur et bien pas tout de suite
puisque les parlementaires d'opposition
ont saisi le conseil constitutionnel qui
va se prononcer cette semaine pour dire
si oui ou non ce projet loi instaurant
le pass vaccinale est conforme à nos
libertés publiques et aux principes de
la constitution donc le pass vaccinale
pour être appliqué en fin de semaine ce
qui donne et bien gouvernement une
semaine de retard dans ce qu'il avait
promis le projet doit donc hier par les
députés quelles sont les réactions
politiques book on vient d'abord du côté
du gouvernement pas d'effusion on peut
regarder par exemple ce tweet du
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand 1
qui est satisfait car avec le pass
vaccinale je cite à la france se dote
d'un nouvel outil pour protéger nos
concitoyens mais quand même pas
d'effusion pas de triomphe de cette
majorité présidentielle dans ce débat
parlementaire aurait été compliqué il a
été arrêté plusieurs fois à l'assemblée
nationale et puis les propos d' emmanuel
macron président de la république dans
cette séquence qui a confié son envie de
sites d'emmerder les non vaccinés eh
bien ça non plus ça n'a pas aidé c'est
un peut cristalliser cet opus est
opposition aux pas actional et une
position relayée par plusieurs familles
politiques alex mais oui par exemple le
rassemblement national marine le pen et
ses députés ont voté contre se passe
hier à l'assemblée tous les groupes de
gauche de l'assemblée nationale
également des insoumis aux socialistes
ont aussi voté contre ce projet de loi
hier et puis également chez les
écologistes on ne voulait pas du tout de
ce pass vaccinale on va écouter le
candidat écolo à la présidentielle
yannick jadot sur ce sujet pourquoi
c'est une mauvaise idée le pass
vaccinale 1 parce que moi ma boussole
depuis le début de cette pandémie c'est
la science et les scientifiques et
encore eu une tribune de 1200
scientifiques sur le co vide la semaine
dernière le conseil scientifique
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
disent il faut convaincre plutôt que
content et puis du côté de la droite
alors c'était un petit peu plus
compliqué il y avait une forme de
malaise au final une majorité de
parlementaires les républicains ont voté
pour le pass vaccinale mais tout en
l'encadrant ai eu beaucoup de
modifications adoptées par la majorité
de droite sénatoriale et puis ces propos
d' emmanuel macron sur les non-vaccinés
ça n'a pas du tout été digéré par la
droite on va écouter l'analyse du
président de l'association des maires de
france et maire les républicains de
cannes david lisnard sur ce point
ce qu'il faut c'est focaliser sur le
besoin de la population or on voit bien
que le post vaccinale est aussi utilisé
comme une arme politique mais le le le
rôle d'anne haddad d'un chef de l'état
et de la politique c'est de régler les
problèmes et de cultiver la concorde
nationale avec ce type de propos
concomitamment au dépôt d'un texte de
loi qui instaure la mesure
mais voilà rien en tout cas une chose
est sûre avec et bien ce contexte
politique de la campagne présidentielle
cela a complètement perturbé court
circuiter ce débat parlementaire sur le
pass d'accès des bacs est devenu très
politique qui sortent du coup
politiquement gagnant de cette séquence
pour voir très difficile de le dire
parce que finalement ce pass vaccinale
qui avait le soutien de l'opinion
publique aujourd'hui ce soutien me
paraissait rodez c'est à dire que quand
on regarde aujourd'hui les dernières
études
dernier sondage sur le jugement des
français concernant la politique
sanitaire c'est évidemment plus large et
ça fait intervenir certainement des
motivations plus hétérogène mais ce
soutien n'est plus majoritaire alors en
effet ça c'est un premier point deuxième
point ça arrive si vous voulez se passe
vaccinale au moment où d'autres pays
finalement sont en train eux-mêmes
d'adopter des politiques assez
différente de celle que l'on était en
train d'adopter je pense à l'espagne qui
est en train en tout cas de s'engager
dans un processus de relâchement des
contraintes sanitaires et de gérer
finalement de vouloir dire en tout cas
vouloir gérer l'épidémie comme une
grippe donc
qu'est-ce que c'est un point positif
pour l'exécutif qui pensaient
véritablement en tout cas faire j'allais
dire de cet usage presque de la crise
sanitaire un moyen d'obtenir un
satisfecit de l'opinion c'est moins vrai
aujourd'hui que ça ne l'était hier moi
je pense que les républicains ont commis
une erreur c'est à dire que
fondamentalement il aurait dû se poser
au pass vaccinale est d'ailleurs ce qui
est intéressant de voir c'est que quand
même le groupe parlementaire à
l'assemblée nationale a été profondément
divisé sur cette question d'abord parce
que il y avait un point de libertés
publiques et il s'était élevé récemment
en tant qu en tant que principal groupe
d'opposition à l'assemblée nationale a
mené ce combat sur les libertés
publiques ensuite parce que tout
simplement le pass vaccinale pose un
problème quant à son efficience
également quant à son efficacité
donc là il y avait je crois un moyen
pour les républicains et pour cela
candidat des républicains de montrer
qu'elle était vraiment différenciante
par rapport à une manuelle macro ils ne
l'ont pas
faire prendre de responsabilités moi je
pense est une erreur politique oui je
pense c'est une erreur politique c'est
en tout cas une anticipation de ce
qu'elle pensait être l'état de l'opinion
publique mais encore une fois l'opinion
publique est en train d'évoluer mais au
delà de la question une opinion publique
avec des questions principes sur
lesquels les libéraux que sont quand
même les républicains auraient pu faire
valoir disons un certain nombre
d'arguments quant à la nécessité ou
quant à la légitimité de ce pass
vaccinale donc je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit une séquence qui soient gagnantes
et d'ailleurs pour emmanuel macron je ne
suis pas sûr que ce soit une séquence
qui font gagner en tout pour les
républicains maintenant reste à savoir à
qui ça profite
oui c'est du pur moi effectivement c'est
aussi du perdant perdant perdant pour le
chef de l'état cpt là où ils pensaient
pouvoir récupérer un crédit politique on
se rend compte que c'est absolument pas
le cas perdant pour une partie de
l'opposition et notamment à droite où
effectivement la majorité a été divisée
en deux et les propos en tout cas
l'attitude de valérie pécresse et pose
pour le moins sur ce sujet énormément
question donc
ceux qui peuvent éventuellement
ressortir est gagnant et je mets des
guillemets à gagnon c'est un petit peu
les oppositions de gauche et du
rassemblement national mais bon est-ce
qu'on ressent vraiment gagnant de
discussion parlementaire aussi un mal
ficelé aussi chaotique et aussi violente
dans ce climat violent qui en partie
instauré par chef de l'état je suis pas
sûr donc c'est des discussions
extrêmement de chaotique est
effectivement ça éclaircit disons une
partie de l'opposition où on voit qui
skie au clair avec ses questions et qui
n'est qu'il n'est pas tout à fait fini
sur cet axe puisque les socialistes et
les insoumis ont saisi et conseil
constitutionnel est ce que c'est
compréhensible pour vous sur un texte
comme celui ci où est ce que c'est de la
politique et pour poursuivre ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure arnaud est ce que
les républicains auraient dû s'associer
du coin cette saisine pour vous je le
pense mais enfin après il fait de ceux
qui décident d'une certaine manière mais
ce qui est vrai c'est que d'ailleurs le
pâtissier s'est un peu évolué sur la
question parce que le parti socialiste
aujourd'hui à voter contre c'est ce que
je comprends lors de la dernière lecture
à l'assemblée nationale c'était il ya
quelques clients oem et c'était pas la
position initiale du groupe du groupe
socialiste de encore les faits le parti
socialiste a compris d'une certaine
manière qu'il y avait là le moyen de
s'opposer sur un sujet fondamental bah
écoutez les parlementaires sont dans
leur rôle en l'occurrence c'est quand
même il faut être clair au delà du
rebond ils font de la politique
peut-être qu'ils font de la politique
m'enfin quand même le pass vaccinale est
un outil qui bouscule un certain nombre
de principes qui sont des principes
fondamentaux de l'eau régime et il me
paraît tout à fait nécessaire que les
parlementaires puissent eux déférés le
texte devant le conseil constitutionnel
ça sera intéressant de voir ce que quel
sera l'avis du porte qu'elle sera plutôt
le le rendu du conseil constitutionnel
sur cette question oh ils ont ils ont eu
tout à fait tout à fait raison de le
faire et même parfois on s'étonne qu'ils
le fassent et on voit que ça sous
l'angle extrêmement politique mais non
non non ils ont ils ont raison je suis
pas sûr que le conseil constitutionnel
satisfasse vraiment le l'exécutif parce
qu'effectivement ce texte bousculés pose
énormément de questions et à mon sens de
problèmes en terme de en termes de
libertés individuelles donc à voir ce
qui va ce qui va en sortir mais will et
les oppositions sont dans le rôle est
effectivement d'autres groupes
parlementaires auraient été bien
inspirés de suivre cette cette démarche
là oui on a l'impression que le
feuilleton est quasiment finie mais la
vraie défaite des manuels macron sait si
jamais le conseil constitutionnel
retoque ce dispositif du pass vaccinale
à ce moment là ce sera très compliqué le
gouvernement devra réécrire le projet
loi et le temps finalement que le
nouveau pacte d'actionnaires entre en
vigueur et bien la vague au micro n'aura
déjà chuté ça pourrait également
rappeler certains épisodes du
quinquennat comme par exemple cette
fameuse loi sécurité globale sur la
protection de l'image des policiers en
manifestation au final ça avait été
retoquée par le conseil constitutionnel
et savez c'est cheap et on n'a même pas
bien l'idée aujourd'hui de ce qui peut
être applicable dans la loi et
finalement un peu été abandonné et du
coup est ce que cette crise sanitaire
dont on disait en tant qu elle allait
profiter à emmanuel macron puisque en
temps de crise on a plutôt tendance à se
retourner vers celui qui incarne le chef
est ce qu'elle risque de se retourner
contre vie et de devenir vous voulez de
sa campagne vous avez raison c'est moins
vrai aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'il ya
quelques semaines vous m'auriez
interrogé j'aurais pensé que la crise
sanitaire était en effet un élément très
protecteur pour le président de la
république au regard de ce que l'on
appelle l'effet drapeau c'est à dire
dans des circonstances tout à fait
exceptionnelles
il ya un resserrement de la nation alors
sa route peut-être une partie de son
jaillir sa base électorale
clairement mais c'est pas suffisant et
on voit aujourd'hui encore une fois que
le jugement et la perception qui est
celle dans partie de l'opinion sur la
façon dont cette crise a été gérée
redevient d'une certaine manière assez
négatif donc il y a là un élément
d'attac pour ses concurrents qui me
paraît se réintroduire dans l'agenda
politique ce qui n'était pas vraiment le
cas encore une fois il ya quelques
semaines d'autant plus que la situation
sur le plan européen est en train
d'évoluer que vous avez des pays en
europe qui ont décidé finalement ou en
tout cas sont entrés encore une fois de
s'engager dans d'autres dans d'autres
temps d'autres politiques la politique
que mène la france dans ce domaine là je
pense que ça va effectivement se
retourner contre lui une fille née à
moins de 100 jours du premier tour là où
moi aussi j'avais pensé qu' il aurait pu
en faire une véritable force politique
en fait à part resserrer son socle
électoral qui sont 19 20% de boomer qui
de toute façon votre ombre pour emmanuel
macron parce que ils ont sauvé la
résidence secondaire et il n'y a pas
assez pas trop d'impôts pour eux et tout
va bien sinon
non mais c'est le socle électoralement
sociologiquement c'est ça c'est pas
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est vrai et
donc emmerder les français c'était pour
ça aussi c'était pour resserrer cet
électorat-là dont emmanuel macron a
besoin et qui aujourd'hui peut pencher
pour valérie pécresse donc cette crise
sanitaire je pense qu emmanuel macron va
avoir un en effet boomerang qui va être
assez violent
c'est à dire que la visée à court terme
de la communication des manuels macron
lorsqu'il a dit qu'il voulait emmerder
je reprends son expression les non
vaccinés c'était en effet une visée gr
électoral c'est-à-dire ressouder son
électorat ça a été saluée tactique non
comme un coup tactique est comme un trou
tactique et extraordinaire moi je pense
que ça risque en effet de continuer à le
poursuivre et que ça vraisemblablement
nuit cette communication a finalement
l'acceptabilité peut-être même du pass
vaccinale y compris par les
parlementaires mais aussi par une partie
de l'opinion publique ça a été un coup
tactique raté on peut le dire car sûr
que vous les manuels un conte s'est
formé une majorité vaccine à ces
français vaccinés un peu exaspéré par
les non vaccinés mais finalement quand
on les interroge sur ses propos du
président de la république eh bien il ne
les approuve pas totalement président de
la république n'aurait pas dû dire ça si
on reprend la formule consacrée et puis
dans cette séquence il ya aussi et bien
un autre événement qui est
et bien très préjudiciable pour le
gouvernement c'est tout ce protocole à
l'école ça c'est un vrai échec avec un
changement de pied plusieurs fois de
jean michel blanckaert sur ce protocole
l école est une vraie galère pour les
parents et ça aussi ça participe du fait
que et bien cette crise sanitaire est en
train de devenir un boulet pour le
présent la république ça c'est un vrai
risque politique la colère
qui agit comme s'il voulait sa paire
corps le saint père colle ça touche les
enseignants mais ça touche pas seulement
les enseignants ça touche les parents ça
touche les enfants encore une fois les
enfants se plaignent beaucoup du
protocole sanitaire et les enfants ce
sont des prescripteurs auprès des
parents les parents sont très quand même
à très attaché au bien-être de leurs
enfants donc ça en effet à mon avis
c'est un boulet que le gouvernement et
surtout de monsieur blanc caire mais
également emmanuel macron risque disons
de de devoir supporter jusqu'au bout de
la deûle à delà de la campagne oui je
pense qu'ils ont fait une erreur
fondamentale depuis quelques semaines
sur l'école que ça ça fait véritablement
perdre beaucoup de points dans une dans
une future campagne et qui a qui
creusent aussi la crise de confiance et
je pense effectivement là que jean
michel blanquer a complètement raté les
objectifs alors
jean castex peut dire on s'adapte et
faire le service après vente sur france
2 2 1 p sert deux attestations forme
comprend absolument rien et quand on
touche effectivement aux enfants aux
comptes ce sont eux qui se mène là on
touche à quelque chose d'intimé et
qu'importe pour qui on vote souvent ça
provoque que de la colère
[Musique]